Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Endlich, endlich wieder vereint äh in der Metaebene.
Endlich wieder in der Mitte, in der umgebauten Meterebene.
Ja, wenn der soweit umgebauten Mieterebene, dass mal wieder alles ganz wacklig und brüchig ist. Aber ich glaube, das haben die Hörer gerade zu vermisst. Diese lange Phase eines stabilen Setups verstört auch irgendwie mit der.
Ja, man will dann auch wieder so ein bisschen Vinyl.
Das ist auch die irakische Grundkomponente, die damit sichergestellt wird. Damit wäre es schon fast.
Bei der Vorstellung unseres Gastes.
Fast bei der Vorstellung unserer Themen würde ich sogar fast sagen.
Nee, wir müssen erst den Gast vorstellen, oder?
Warte mal, bevor wir zum Gast kommen. Ähm ich habe jetzt die Videoaufzeichnung gesehen von unserer äh Veranstaltung bei den Datenspuren. Die werde ich jetzt demnächst auch nochmal veröffentlichen,
mit Bonusmaterial.
Ja
Preshow. Preshow. Das gibt's ja hier sonst gar nicht, ne? Naja, das wollte ich nur noch mal kurz gesagt haben. Na dann äh stellen wir doch mal unseren Gast vor.
Der kann sich selber vorstellen.
Sagen hallo zu Ronny, hallo.
Hallo, ich bin der Ronny von Dass Kraftfutter Mischwerk und bin hier heute der Gast.
Das hast du sehr schön gemacht.
Ronny hat, der Ronny hat uns eine Geschichte zu erzählen, aber bevor der Ronny seine Geschichte erzählt, muss ich äh kurz die irakische Grundkomponente sichern und meine der letzten Woche korrigieren. Und zwar ähm.
Genau. Und zwar ähm also musste ich das Errater korrigieren, sondern ausrufen. Ausrufen. Naja, das Ira.
Ausrufen, ja. Ne, wer weiß, ob ich das nicht irgendwann auch noch mal korrigieren muss. Ähm.
Ja, das Ganze.
Schutzfristen für Tonaufnahmen gelten nicht über den Tod hinaus.
Also wir haben letztes Mal bisschen über Urheberrecht gesprochen und.
Haben danach die Sendung betitelt.
Ja, na ja gut, das bezog sich ja an sich,
Der Titel ist schon noch in Ordnung, weil ich sprach in dem Zusammenhang auch generell über das Urheberrecht sozusagen, wie wir es bisher kennen. Und da geht es halt über den Tod hinaus. Dummerweise war halt genau das, worüber wir jetzt
was der konkrete Anlass war, darüber zu sprechen, nämlich die Verlängerung der Schutzfristen für Tonaufnahmen eben nicht eine solche Regelung. So sind wir.
Das haben wir dann mal indossiv von verlinkt. An dieser Stelle vielen Dank an David, der uns darauf hingewiesen hat.
Genau, das heißt äh auch, dass uns sehr aufmerksam zugehört wird, dass doch auch mal was. Von guten Leuten. Ja.
Von guten Leuten. Und ähm Andre Meister hatte auch äh eine äh einen Erratung anzubringen,
In diesem Falle seinen Artikel betreffend, in den ich behauptete, in Russland würden Agenturer Punkt RU Citizon Lab und Privacy International zensiert. Genau die werden nicht zensiert, sondern sie haben die Zensurliste,
irgendwie sich mal angeschaut und darüber berichtet. Und ich verlinke auch die Prüfseite zur Zensur, also da gibt's eine,
Seite, die haben quasi ihr die die Liste ist nicht veröffentlicht, aber es gibt eine Seite, wo man einzelne Domains prüfen kann, das heißt, es wird dann jetzt bald irgendwelche Scraper gebastelt werden, die dann daraus eine Liste bauen. Ähm ich habe dann mal ein Logbuch Netzpolitik eingegeben
Und die Antwort äh ist dann leider in
Deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob wir in Russland zensiert werden, wissen wir gerade, Ronny äh hier in der in der nie veröffentlichten Preshow, sagte
Ja, gibt das doch mal bei Google ein. Und äh das habe ich dann gemacht und die die offizielle, das offizielle Verdickt, lautet,
Warte mal. Das offizielle lautet ich suche die Adresse nicht in der Registrierung erscheinen Komma.
Laut Google. Insofern werden wir, glaube ich, in Russland nicht zensieren.
Normal sagen?
Ähm ja, ich suche die Adresse nicht in der äh Registrierscheinen-Kommer.
Aber irgendwer weiß das bestimmt.
Also ich ich denke, das heißt, dass wir in Russland nicht zensiert werden. Was will uns der Russe damit sagen?
Bist du sicher, dass du das bei Google noch nicht bei Google eingegeben hast, klingt so ein bisschen mehr wie eine Antwort von Yoda.
Ja.
Tenziert diese Seite nicht ist oder doch, ist? Also sind wir jetzt zensiert oder nicht?
Mist. Äh müssen mehr ähm.
Total gefährlich.
Selbstmordanleitung für Kinder äh hier unterbringen, dann werden wir gesperrt.
Oder oder ein russisches senden.
Genau. Während sie gerade in der Kirche ein Lied singen gegen Putin.
Wir sagen einfach einmal und schon ist diese.
Schon kommt das weiße Rauschen.
Ja in Deutschland kann man ja noch ähm ungestört veröffentlichen, Ronny, oder? Ja.
Ja also zumindest ohne zensiert zu werden, aber im Zweifelsfall mit einer dicken Kostennote bedacht zu werden.
Was ist dir passiert.
Na, grundsätzlich mir jetzt eher nur so,
der Schwanz irgendwie von einer langen Geschichte. Irgendwie ging vor vier Wochen los, dass eine Berliner Bildagentur namens HGMpress zusammen mit einer,
Kanzlei in Hannover anfing Blogger wegen Urheberrechtsverletzungen
abzumahnen mit einer enormen Kostennote. Da ging's beim ersten Fall um irgendwie so einen Autoblock. Die hatten wohl über irgendeine Auto berichtet, hatten dafür drei Fotos benutzt und haben irgendwie von der
äh Kanzlei im Auftrag der äh Bildagentur eine Abmahnote, Kostennote von neunzehntausend Euro bekommen für die drei Fotos,
waren natürlich tierisch erschrocken,
Na weil es wohl hieß, dass es dafür keine Nutzungsrechte gab, die halt benutzen zu dürfen. Wir waren halt tierisch erschrocken, haben auch irgendwie ziemlich gleich alles dicht gemacht, haben alle Bilder, weil sich rausgeschmissen, waren halt verunsichert,
danach kam aber raus, dass die, also die Leute, die für die Fotos verantwortlich waren, dieses Blog regelrecht gebeten haben, die Fotos bei sich zu benutzen, um über irgendeine Kiste zu berichten, was halt diese Autos betrifft,
Also die hatten ausdrücklich die Genehmigung und die Bitte, diese Fotos zu benutzen.
Nicht dieselben, die dann auch gleich abgemahnt haben. Nee. Weil ich meine, das wäre natürlich eine richtig geile Nummer.
Na, das ist ja halt so das Problem, dass man ja selber nie weiß, was mit den Rechten passiert. Also selbst als Fotograf hebst du die Rechte irgendwem, gerade wenn du irgendwo im Ausland sitzt,
Und ab da äh beendet ja deine Verfügung äh über die Fotos, weil dann entscheidet die Agentur, was mit den Bildern passiert,
und da ist es in dem Fall ist es so, dass die Abmahnung zurückgezogen wurde. Es gab aber keine Entschuldigung, hieß dann irgendwie ist ein Missverständnis äh bis nächste Mal so in etwa und das war's,
Typen sitzen halt auf den Anwaltskosten, die sie ja trotzdem haben, für ihren Anwalt,
den sie halt bezahlen müssen weiterhin. Und eine ähnliche Geschichte war mit diesem, mit diesem Lego-Künstler, Nathan Salvaja, da gab's mehrere Blogs, die da dann angeschrieben wurden von der Agentur, weil's um bestimmtes Foto ging,
auch unter der Prämisse, dass die halt die Nutzungsrechte dafür haben und da haben sich einige Blogger halt denn an den Künstlern selber gewandt,
und der Künstler meinte dann halt so, dass er seine, also dass die Nutzungsrechte, die Fotos und alle von seiner Freundin und er hätte die niemals irgendwo irgendwem verkauft.
Hm
Also auch da gab's keinen, keinen Anspruch dieser dieser Agentur und der Kanzlei und auch da war es wieder selber, hieß es dann ja, war ein Missverständnis passiert,
Müsst ihr jetzt halt gucken und dann haben die halt och gesagt, wir wollen aber jetzt nicht hier gucken, sondern wir wollen auch die Kohle für unseren Anwalt wiederhaben. Und da weigern die sich nach wie vor. Halt sich da irgendwie rechtlich zu vergleichen.
Wie kamen die denn auf die Idee, dass sie die Rechte hätten? Also ich meine.
Das ist eine interessante Frage. Kann sie wirklich keiner nachvollziehen. Also irgendwie müssen sie wohl, also bei dem ersten, bei dieser ersten Geschichte mit den Autos war's wohl so, dass die tatsächlich die Rechte haben, aber die eigentlichen Urheber,
quasi im Vorfeld schon die Nutzungsrechte für dieses bestimmte Blog irgendwie weitergegeben haben.
Sich danach erst dann an diese Agentur das.
So so wahrscheinlich. Also die wussten wahrscheinlich nicht mal voneinander, so wirklich
und bei dieser ist es so, dass es bis heute nicht geklärt. Also da der hat halt gesagt, er hat die nie weitergegeben, hat da irgendwie auch noch eine eine Pressemitteilung zugeschrieben und daraufhin wurden halt die
zurückgezogen, aber das war es halt. Die sagen halt nach wie vor diese Agentur, dass das äh diese Rechte an diesen Bildern nicht endgültig geklärt sind.
Und deswegen gehören sie, gehen sie erstmal davon aus, dass es ihre sind.
Das ist total interessant, dass man, bevor ich eine Abmahnung rausschicke, sollte ich ja darüber Sicherheit haben, ob die Rechte mir zustehen oder nicht, das machen die halt nicht. Also zumindest in den beiden Fällen nicht. Dann gab's
irgendwie eine nächste Nummer mit irgendwie einem uralten Cosplaybild aus China, glaube ich, irgendwie so ein Handy-Schnappschuss, irgendwie so ein Ironman-Cosplay-Kostüm Dingsi.
Das ist Cosplay.
Wenn sich so äh Jugendliche oder vielleicht auch nicht Jugendliche so verkleiden, wie Comicfiguren oder sonstige Superhelden et cetera. Genau.
Da ging's halt um so eine so eine Ironman-Geschichte und da sieht's wohl im Moment so aus, dass die tatsächlich über irgendwelche Wege diese Rechte äh erworben haben oder von einer anderen Agentur irgendwie im Ausland zugesprochen haben äh bekommen haben,
und äh da ist jetzt ist man jetzt soweit, dass einige Blogger halt sagen, die bezahlen dafür und andere Anwälte sagen, dass diese
Dieser Weg der Nutzung, dieser Nutzungsrechtsübertragung nicht wirklich äh konkret dokumentiert ist und da geht's dann darum, dass halt irgendwer eine E-Mail schrieb, ihr könnt die Rechte jetzt nutzen, aber
Anwälte sind halt der Meinung, dass es nicht reicht, sondern dass es wirklich vertraglich geregelt sein muss und halt auch wirklich bis, ja, genau, sowas.
Das heißt, es war ein ähm jetzt nur noch hm, wie lange waren denn diese dieses Ironman Cosplay-Bild dann schon irgendwie im Internet?
Glaube, das von zwo neun.
So, das heißt, so zweitausendneun haben irgendwie die Leute die Blogs angefangen, dieses Bild zu bloggen,
man könnte jetzt die Theorie entfalten, das es eine Agentur gibt, der die gemerkt hat, ach das Bild ist auf relativ vielen Blogs, das würde sich eigentlich lohnen, dafür die Nutzungsrechte zu haben, um die alle abzumahnen.
Also wäre, ist, ist eine Vermutung, aber also ich will das gar nicht, also ich will das halt nicht behaupten, weil weil manchmal ist es halt wirklich so, dass es halt schwer ist, äh nachzuvollziehen, wo welche
Bilder irgendwo hingehen und gerade die Rechte. Was an der Sache halt interessant ist, dass die Agentur innerhalb der vier letzten vier Wochen mindestens äh zweiundzwanzig Blocks ab
gemahnt hat, also von denen ich selber auch weiß
um mittlerweile deine Kostenforderungen in Höhe von über siebzigtausend Euro entstanden sind. Und das halt schon äh spürbar, wie aggressiv und wie brutal,
finanziell halt vorgehen. Man könnte ja auch sagen, hier hat da irgendwie ein Bild benutzt, wo ihr damals nicht die Rechte hattet,
und ihr müsst da jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen was für Zahlen und die nehmt die wieder runter, damit kann man ja leben, aber die machen halt auch keine Angaben darüber, seit wann sie die Nutzungsrechte besitzen,
Ist halt auch nicht irgendwie ganz geklärt. Und ist halt irgendwie alles ein bisschen schwammig.
Haben immer so eine Forderung, die ist immer vierstellig. Die ist zwölfhundert, achtzehnhundert.
Ist soweit also von den von dieser Autokiste waren's neunzehntausend für drei Fotos.
Aber gut, da haben sie wahrscheinlich dann auch kommerzielle Nutzung oder sowas noch unter äh stellt oder was, ne, oder was.
Also die haben haben halt immer ganz lustige äh Klauseln und Kostenaufstellungen. Also du zahlst halt in erster Linie für die Nutzung des Fotos die Gebühr, zahlst dann nochmal einen hundertprozentigen Aufschlag für den äh für die
Urheberrechtsverletzung und dann kommt halt noch die dickere Anwaltskohle obendrauf,
Ja und jetzt ist es halt so, dass äh vor also letzte Woche gingen dann Wiederabmahnungen raus und zwar geht's da um so eine so eine Schlangentorte. Hat irgendwie so eine Engländerin,
im Sommer des Jahres hat halt 'ne Schlange gemacht die aussieht wie 'n Pyton, wie so 'n gelber burmesischer Python irgendwie und ziemlich abgefahren und das Ding taucht da auf und ich hab's.
Das war nur die Torte sah aus wie der Python oder oder.
Genau, genau. Also nicht der Python, der aussah wie eine Torte. Nee, es ist.
Ich habe das Bild gesehen und dachte, naja, ist ein Python liegt im Kreis.
Nee, ist tatsächlich ein.
Viel Fantasie sieht ja aus wie eine.
Nein, es ist tatsächlich eine Torte, die die Frau irgendwie für ihre Tochter gemacht hatte, weil die meine außergewöhnliche Torte haben wollte.
Und die macht halt so und so so Kuchenzeug irgendwie und famt damit halt auch irgendwie im Netz. Und auf jeden Fall hat die diese Torte gebacken, hat die dann auf Facebook geteilt irgendwie, ich glaube Ende August,
Juli. Genau und,
Ja, hat dann sich da auch gefreut, dass die ganzen Leute das teilen und hat dann auch auf Blogs verlinkt, die die Torte selber auch bei sich geblockt haben, was rückblickend sehr interessant ist
hat sich halt auch wirklich über die über äh den Fame irgendwie gefreut, der im Netz entstanden ist,
Und ich hatte das damals irgendwie geblockt, weil ich's halt auf Facebook irgendwie gefunden habe, habe dummerweise nicht gefragt, bin naiv wie ich bin davon ausgegangen, dass es ihr irgendwie zu Gute kommt, wenn man da irgendwie drauf linkt und da hat sie ja auch irgendwie auch was von,
Und dann war erstmal Ruhe im Schacht und jetzt kam halt,
Letzte Woche von der HGM Press, die Abmahnungen mit dem Verweis, dass die ja halt die Bildrechte besitzen würden für diese Tortenfotos.
Und da also um das zu belegen war halt eine E-Mail drinne, die vom neunundzwanzigsten zehnten ist, also jetzt vierzehn Tage alt, von der Frau, die in der E-Mail halt versichert, dass die Nutzungsrechte für Deutschland bei der HGM liegen
Ja und da ist aber irgendwie ein Zeitraum von acht Wochen, der Screenshot, den sie bei mir gemacht haben, ist kurz nach kurz äh nachdem ich die Fotos damals geblockt habe, entstanden,
und die Abmahnung kam aber erst jetzt, also da liegen locker irgendwie acht Wochen zwischen. Was mich persönlich irgendwie ein bisschen wundert.
Aha.
Weil ich davon ausgehe, dass man schneller sein kann als Agentur. Weil ich weiß, es gibt einen Fall von letzter Woche, da sind irgendwie Anfang der Woche Bilder aufgetaucht und vier Tage später war die Abmahnung da. Meine Vermutung ist, dass halt
jetzt so lange gedauert hat, um an die Mail von der Frau zu kommen, die halt belegen soll, dass die Nutzungsrechte bei der deutschen Agentur liegen.
Das heißt, also wie gesagt, die Idee liegt also irgendwie nahe, dass sie sich die Nutzungsrechte erst nachher holen, wenn die Bilder viral sind.
Nein, das kann in dem Fall natürlich auch sein,
Ich habe da jetzt eine ganze Weile irgendwie recherchiert und ich hatte das Bild gebracht und da gab es noch nicht ausgewiesene Nutzungsrechte, zumindest nicht für den deutschen Raum
und erst ein paar Tage später brachte die Sun in England
Und da war dann auf einmal äh BMPS, die britische Agentur, die britische Bildagentur, hatte denn irgendwie die Credits da drunter?
Und äh die HGM vertritt wohl BNPS in Deutschland. Kann sein, dass die quasi die Nutzungsrechte erst gekauft haben, nachdem ich das Bild schon geblockt hatte.
Und da ist halt die Frage, wie man da äh rechtlich mit umgehen sollte, weil ich glaube, es gibt dafür keine rechtliche Grundlage,
Es gibt halt immer so Sachen, die gerade wenn du wenn du so so Netzwerkkisten hast, wie weiß ich, äh Tumbler oder oder äh reddit oder die Suppe oder Facebook. Und der Grundgedanke daran liegt, Dinge zu teilen.
Heute Nacht gab's irgendwie so ein tierisch abgefahrenes Beispiel, dass auf Radit ein Foto gelandet von einem Typ, der einfach sein Wasser fotografiert hat, wie wie's in die Spüle reinläuft. Also im Grunde genommen nix Großes, sieht aber wirklich aus wie ein Auge und ist halt optisch ein absoluter Hingucker
Der hatte innerhalb von fünf Stunden hatte der über hunderttausend Bewertungen äh Bewertungen, was selbst Foredid extrem viel ist,
Und das war halt fünf Stunden im Netz. Es ging halt komplett rum und jetzt ist halt die Frage, was passiert, wenn der nächste Woche die Nutzungsrechte dafür verkauft?
Obwohl das quasi ins Netz gegeben hat, um es zu teilen
Also ist ja irgendwie so ein Grundgedanke. Ich kann natürlich auch Bilder machen, kann die Mimi aufs Block tun und kann sagen, kann einfach auf eine Copyright Note runter tun, war halt was, was bei dieser bei dieser Torte da irgendwie auch nicht der Fall war. Es machte den Eindruck, dass es halt in die Welt raus soll.
Und inwiefern die konkrete Abmahnung jetzt wirklich äh gerechtfertigt ist, lasse ich gerade vom Anwalt klären, weil nach den ersten Zwillingen dann mit Autodino und dem Leokünstler ist mir natürlich nicht wirklich klar, inwiefern die wirklich gerechte Besitzung,
und da muss ich jetzt halt einen Anwalt drum kümmern
Und ich weiß, dass es gerade in Bezug auf diese Agentur nicht der einzige Fall ist, wo Anwälte jetzt sagen, da zahlen wir jetzt nicht, da gucken wir jetzt erstmal, inwiefern die Abmahnung wirklich gerechtfertigt sind und,
versuchen uns dann irgendwie mit denen zu einigen.
Hast du so ein bisschen Einblick
bekommen so in die äh in die Verteidigungs äh Praxis. Also ich kenne das jetzt nur so aus diesen typischen Fallshering, Betonsachen. Das ist ja nochmal ein bisschen anders gelagert, aber grundsätzlich kann man wohl
sagen. Nur weil man jetzt mal eine Abmahnung ins Haus kriegt, ist noch lange nicht äh äh,
alles vorbei, ja, sondern da gibt's durchaus äh gerade in dem Moment, wo man sich hinstellt, die Brust aufbläht und sagt so, was seid denn ihr für Vögel so, ja, das Ganze vielleicht auch noch juristisch korrekt formuliert, ähm dann.
Grundsätzlich ist ja so, dass die natürlich, also macht halt auch diese Masse der Abmahnungen wie klar, äh die haben, wie gesagt, in den letzten vier Wochen über zwanzig Abmahnungen rausgekloppt mit einer riesengroßen Kostennoten und wenn die da zwei, drei finden, die das bezahlen, so wie das kommt, weil sie halt ein bisschen Angst,
lohnt sich das schon für die Juristen sagen halt, dass so eine Abmahnung, kann ich auch dir schicken
aus irgendeiner Begründung such mir halt 'ne Anwalt und sag du hast von mir genutzt, ich will jetzt dafür Geld haben und dann musst du halt oder dein Anwalt entscheiden, ob du das bezahlen möchtest oder sollst, oder dagegenst und wir sind jetzt halt an dem Punkt, wo wir sagen, das würdet nicht so ohne Weiteres bezahlen möchten,
und dass Juristen halt auch sagen, dass die Dokumentations äh,
Praxis, die die halt führen, einfach da einen Screenshot von einer E-Mail mit drin, dass das halt lange nicht ausreichend ist, um zu belegen, ob die wirklich die Rechte an den Bildern besitzen,
und da sagen halt auch äh Juristen, da halten wir jetzt einfach mal die Füße still und gucken, was daraus kommt. Wir fordern jetzt halt wirklich eine lückenlose Dokumentation. Dieser dieser Rechtsvergabe,
Vergebung. Und dann sehen wir halt weiter. So so ist jetzt der Stand der Juristen und es gibt natürlich immer noch irgendwie,
Forderungen von den ersten zwei Abmahnungen, die wohl offenbar wirklich äh unrechtens waren, dass die äh Kanzlei, beziehungsweise die Agentur, die Anwaltskosten der Abgemahnten übernimmt,
Und ich weiß nicht genau, wie.
Weil sie sich die auch noch leisten kann.
Ja, du weißt nicht genau, wie der Stand ist, also ich weiß, dass es äh Anwälte gibt, die halt sagen, wir klagen die zurück,
und grundsätzlich ist es wohl wichtig, dass dass es früher oder später wirklich mal rechtlich entschieden wird
damit man irgendwie Referenzurteile schaffen kann, damit man halt wirklich, weil bis jetzt, glaube ich, sind die Fälle,
relativ selten, wo wirklich Leute bis vor Gericht gehen, weil natürlich ist es klar, man hat irgendwie einen Urheberrechtsverstoß äh begangen, also da braucht man auch gar nicht drüber reden, das ist halt tatsächlich der Fall. Die Frage ist halt nur, inwiefern und in welcher Höhe der bestraft werden sollte.
Und es gab ja immer mal diese diese politische Idee der Abmahndeckelung mit einer bestimmten Summe
die im Erstfall irgendwie bezahlt werden sollte, gab war glaube ich auch bei diesem bittet und Tauschbörsen für Musik irgendwie mal hundert Euro im Erstfall
also gibt's halt auch äh äh rechtliche Grauzonen, wo man, wenn man halt sagt, wenn's neue Musik ist, wird's irgendwie gewerbsmäßig ertrieben und dann sind die hundert Euro weg. Also auch da tun sich Kanzleien irgendwie noch mal ein Zubrot verdienen. Aber es gibt dieses Urteil, soweit ich weiß nicht, für Fotos,
Und da wird's halt Zeit, dass da irgendwie ein Urteil herkommt und auch politisch irgendwie was passiert.
Ja ist eigentlich
Trauerspiel, das äh Juristen, ich meine gerade die, die sozusagen deren Aufgabe es ist, äh Dinge genau herzuleiten, ja, äh ausgerechnet in diesem Abmahnbereich, wo es so einen Potentialen ähm,
Kollateralschaden geben kann, dass dass die nicht von vornherein auf mehr Sorgfalt
verpflichtet werden. Das das ist das, was mich eigentlich äh im Kern daran stört. Ich meine, ich will ja gar nicht sagen, dass Abmahnungen an sich jetzt Ivil sind, weil,
uns auch genug Szenarien vorstellen, wo man äh ein berechtigtes Interesse da auch äh geltend machen will so, aber dann muss man eben auch klar äh belegen können, so hier gucke mal, so sieht's aus. Äh jetzt äußert euch.
Das haltet Problem, gerade in den ersten beiden Fällen, die da passiert sind, dass im Nachhinein irgendwie klar ist, dass die da die Rechte gar nicht an den Bildern haben und dann wird's halt wirklich problematisch so.
Natürlich als abgemeinter auf den Kosten sitzen bleibst, weil deine Reputation quasi im Arsch ist,
muss man halt so sehen. Du bist dann ist halt auch grad so eine Debatte, auf denen auf den Blogs, äh die halt stattfindet, du bist halt der Urheberrechtsverletzer und das ist gar nicht festgelegt, ob das irgendwie entschieden ist, also juristisch auch untermauert
oder ob
die halt denken, du bist der Urheberrechtsverletzer, weil gibt denn halt auch Fälle, wo abgesprochen war mit bestimmten Künstlern, dass du diese Bilder benutzen darfst, wie halt in diesem Autodino-Ding
da war das halt wirklich so eine Kooperation zwischen Blogger und Fotografen.
Vielleicht auch mal noch ganz kurz anzumerken. Ich glaube, dass du wahrscheinlich bisher noch nicht tausend, noch was Euro mit deinem Block verdient hast. Ähm,
Und dass dein dein Blogkonzept, also dein das Blog, das Kraftfutter, eine Kraftfuttermischweg DE Slash Blog äh ist, glaube ich, WL. Ähm,
eigentlich schon eines der Größeren äh Multiplikatoren bloss Deutschlands ist, die eigentlich, weiß ich nicht, was hast du so für eine Artikelfrequenz, fünf, sechs Artikel am Tag mit irgendwelchen coolen Sachen.
Manchmal zwanzig, manchmal ein paar weniger, ist immer unterschiedlich.
Am Tag neue Blogeinträge und was mich fertig,
Ich glaube, ich habe in diesem Jahr noch keine zwanzig Blogeinträge geschrieben.
Ja, ihr schreibt ja auch immer.
Na du machst dir auch selber, du klaust ja nicht einfach die Bilder.
Ja, dann würde das schneller gehen.
Genau, ich muss ja erstmal im Fotografen beauftragen.
Genau, richtig.
Erstmal bist du erstmal die ganzen Nutzungsrechte.
Kriege ich jetzt so eine scheiß Schlange her? Halbe Stunde habe ich davor gesessen, bis ich das Ding richtig geringelt hat.
Und das Licht dann noch.
Das Licht dann.
Nee, aber wenn worauf du hinaus willst, ist wahrscheinlich, dass dass man da irgendwie eine Unterscheidung machen sollte zwischen kommerziellen und unkommerziellen Blogs.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, ne? Also das muss man einfach mal äh also ne, ich meine über über tausend Euro ist äh ist muss ein alter Blogger lange für bloggen.
Ja, aber ich glaube, dass sie die Unterscheidung gar nicht machen und ich glaube, dass da doch unheimlich schwer ist, weil die haben ja doch Blocks abgemeint, die überhaupt keine Werbung machen.
Also gar nichts und äh die Frage ist, da fragt ja dann auch keiner, selbst wenn du irgendwie Google Ads drauf hast, unter sechsundvierzig Cent im Monat machst, wie viel verdienst du damit, ist für die völlig irrelevant,
kloppen komplett die Gelder raus. Und das macht's halt auch unheimlich schwierig, da eine Unterscheidung zu treffen
also zu sagen, ja, der blockt jetzt äh unkommerziell und der blockt jetzt kommerziell und wir müssen das anderen anders berechnen, wenn jemand irgendwie damit Geld verdient, ist unheimlich schwierig und meines Erachtens auch nicht wirklich machbar, weil du musst halt dann konkret unterscheiden, wo beginnt Werbung und,
beginnt, also ein kommerzieller Erwerb
beginnt halt mit dem Google Ad. Egal, wie viel det bringt, damit bist du quasi ein kommerzieller Blogger und selbst wenn du diese Werbung nicht drin hast, um die Woche fünf Artikel schreibst, für die du Geld bekommst.
Kennzeichnest, bist du halt ein gewerblicher Blogger, also das ist irgendwie ganz schwierig, das zu klassifizieren
und deshalb würde ich es viel wichtiger finden, dass man wirklich eine Regelung, also eine Gesamtregelung schafft, die nicht so verdammt schmerzhaft ist
zumal ja
Also für mich ist halt einfach das Ding, bestimmte Dinge, die ich vor fünf Jahren oder so geblockt habe, habe ich überhaupt nicht das Bewusstsein gehabt, dass da irgendwie irgendwann mal ein Fotograf sagen könnte für hier, jetzt wollen wir aber mal Geld sehen, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, habe ich nie drüber nachgedacht in dem Moment
und diese Kiste schafft halt ein ganz anderes Bewusstsein und das ist vielleicht ist das auch was, was diese Agentur erreichen will, aber ich werde mir halt zehn Mal überlegen, ob ich irgendein bescheuertes Schlangenkuchen noch mal bringe von irgend so einer Uschi. Wenn ich halt weiß, dass ich dafür aufn Sack kriege, also det,
Muss ich ganz klar sagen.
Bin ich echt fuffzehn Artikel am Tag machst, dann schlummert bei dir ja noch einiges äh im Archiv.
Habe da auch schon einige Nächte verbracht,
um da Klarheit zu schaffen. Aber im Grunde genommen ist das für einen Arsch, weil die schon seit Wochen und seit Monaten halt die Blogs durchgucken und wenn du jetzt anfängst zu löschen, äh ist wahrscheinlich
eh zu spät. Du musst halt nur gucken, dass du wenn du wenn du dieses Risiko weiterhin einigen willst, dass da einfach anders mit deinem Content umgehst.
Vor allem.
Vor allem die Software müsste auch mal ein bisschen anders mit dem Content umgehen, man das prangere ich auch äh an, dass äh ich meine, wenn du so Blogging-Software benutzt und so, ja, die macht's dir auch einfach äh wenig drüber nachzudenken.
Sie macht's ihr nicht einfach äh auch mal Regeln einzuhalten. Ich meine, warum kann ein Wordpress
nicht generell sagen, oh hier ein Bild, was ist denn da die Lizenz, ja, wo ist die Seite, wo ich draufklicke, wo alle Bilder, wo es nicht explizit von mir geklärt wurde, ja, also man kann sich das auch nicht anzeigen lassen, es gibt,
da keinerlei äh äh Möglichkeiten. Ich habe auch immer wieder das Problem, wenn ich irgendwie mir selbst so zusammensuche. Es ist nicht auch einfach mal eben,
Also da steht dann die Lizenz auch nicht drin im Bild, ja? Also man das wäre auch zu überlegen, ob man nicht auch sagt, äh wenn die so automatisiert vorgehen mit ihren Bildern, ja, dann müssen sie irgendwie auch,
sicherstellen, dass,
oder sollte man, gut, das kann man, kann man nicht sicherstellen, wenn's kopiert wird, insofern ist es schwierig, aber grundsätzlich frage ich mich, warum sind Bilder nicht einfach auch entsprechend getagt? Warum steht
der Autor die Rechte et cetera nicht im Bild äh konkret selber in den Metadaten drin. Und ähm.
Was jetzt sozusagen sich noch anschließt an diese ganze äh Debatte, ist ja auch ähm wie ich jetzt auch gerade dran, das hatte ich hier mit Matthias Spielkamp, als ich im CRE mal über äh Urheberrecht äh generell gesprochen habe,
Ob es nicht langsam mal mehr an der Zeit wäre, auch zu fordern,
eben diese ganze Beweislast dahingehend umzudrehen, dass eben Copyreited Material einfach gemeldet werden muss,
Derzeit ist es so, du schaffst irgendwas und das Urheberrecht äh äh gilt und und und schon hast du die den Baseballschläger in der Hand und das ist sozusagen das Problem. Wenn es aber so eine klare Instanz gäbe,
wo man eben mit irgendeiner ID et cetera wirklich auch hinterlegt und sagt, für dieses Werk will ich jetzt überhaupt das Urheberrecht auch erstmal
gelten lassen und wenn ich das nicht getan habe, dann ist es nicht so. Was ja auch den Vorteil hätte, dass es auch ein ganz klarer Zeit,
Referenz gäbe, et cetera. Ja, grad so im Hinblick mit vorher benutzt, nachher benutzt.
Ja, das ist ja, ist ja gerade in diesem Fall ist ja stellt sich ja halt die Frage, äh weil klar, wenn die diese Torte auf Facebook rufpack, will die, also geht die davon aus, dass das geteilt werden kann,
Das ist der Sinn von Facebook. Also nicht, dass du das jetzt runterlädst und wieder woanders hochlegst, ist nochmal eine andere Kiste. Aber du kannst ja äh ganz einfach auf teilen klicken und hast dieses Foto auf deinem Profil
So gehört einfach dazu. Und die hat wahrscheinlich auch diesen, diese Torte nicht gebacken und hat gedacht,
boah da verkoffe ich jetzt die Bildrechte. Also det ist quasi dadurch entstanden, dass ich das multipliziert habe und daraufhin eine Agentur wahrscheinlich aufmerksam wurde und gesagt hat, wir würden jetzt hier für die Bildrechte kaufen
und natürlich weiß ich doch als normaler Mensch ja nicht, bei wem welche Bildrechte liegen
Also wenn ich halt ein Foto irgendwo finde, gerade diese redet nun mal mit diesem Spülbecken ist halt eine ganz gutes Beispiel,
ist heute halt immens gefragt. Ich habe das bei mir irgendwie gebracht. Das ist in zwei Jahren ist das Thema durch. Wahrscheinlich dauert das gar nicht so lange, in acht Wochen ist wahrscheinlich das Bild schon lange wieder durch
Und denn meldet sich eine Fotoagentur und sagt, wir haben dit gekauft. Jetzt musst du dafür zahl,
finde ich schwierig. Und gerade im Fall von HGM ist es ja so, die haben natürlich einen Bundle an Bildern und du hast als normaler Mensch aber eher nicht die Möglichkeit, dir die angucken zu können, also die eben das nur an Redaktion raus, an ähm äh Medien, aber als ganz normaler,
User hast du auch ja nicht die Möglichkeit, die zu lizensieren, was ich auch sehr interessant finde,
medialen Hintergrund haben, um an diese Bilder überhaupt ranzukommen. Sonst darfst du die nicht mal lizensieren.
Ja, also das ist auch es ist, glaube ich, relativ klar, dass man bei Bildern,
vor allem wenn das ein Schlangenkuchen ist, äh der schon ein paar Monate alt ist, dass sich das Bild jetzt nicht mehr so großartig ähm als Agentur verkaufen kann und dass sich da wahrscheinlich bessere Einnahmen.
Also dieser Verdacht liegt halt wirklich nahe und meine Wand halt äh ganz witzig ist, irgendwie Ole Reismann vorm Spiegel hatte, da mal irgendwie angerufen und hat da mal ganz äh soft nachgefragt
bei der Kanzlei und die schreiben sich halt auf die Fahnen des Urheberrechts, äh den Urheberrecht
irgendwie zu schätzen und man müsse die Urheber auch bewahren und es ging um nichts anderes als wirklich nur darum
und das das Maß ist voll und wir müssen jetzt mal klare Kante fahren. So ist irgendwie die Argumentation. Aber keiner von denen hat vorher probiert irgendwie mal die softe Kante zu fahren, also die knüppeln gleich voll raus.
Und die gehen ganz fest davon aus, dass da noch einige hinterher kommt. Also das übrig noch lange nicht allen.
Ich denke, ich denke, die haben irgendwie alle äh nachzuarbeiten. Übrigens auch die sozialen Netzwerke. Ich meine, die machen immer das Teilen sehr leicht, ja? Aber sie haben zum Beispiel keinerlei Mechanismus, der ist dann eben auch sehr leicht macht, das
und das war irgendwie auch klar und es ist nun mal geschützt, ja, dass dass man sozusagen,
Ich sage jetzt mal, ist vielleicht etwas umstritten, aber so ähnlich wie das grad mit der GEMA bei YouTube funktioniert, ja, so wurde da sozusagen etwas festgestellt, verschwindet es ja quasi auch automatisch aus allen Blogs
bei Bildern nicht unbedingt so. Ich meine klar, jeder kann dann immer noch mal runterladen und selber hochladen, selber Schuld, ja, aber wenn man sozusagen safe sein will, also ein Safe-Sharing macht,
wo er sagt, okay, ich weiß es jetzt zwar nicht,
Solange es ungeklärt ist, ist das Bild jetzt mal hier, aber in dem Moment, wo klar geklärt wird, dass ich das jetzt nicht hätte tun dürfen
dann kann eben auch die andere Seite, ohne dass ich irgendetwas tun muss, ist bei mir auch einfach ausblenden und dann ist auch gut und dann bin ich auch raus
dem Schneider, ja? Und das, da sind auch solche Mechanismen, die derzeit ähm einfach gar nicht
äh da sind und die letzten Endes allen Beteiligten das Leben sehr viel einfacher machen würden, vorausgesetzt, dass es den Urheber nun wirklich darum geht, dass ja das
nicht wollten, dass das so äh veröffentlicht wird.
Also der Tipp bei diesem, bei diesem Ironman Cosplay ist es so, dass betroffene Blogger den angeschrieben haben,
und der halt meinte, dass dat absolut daneben findet, dass Agenturen jetzt auch mit dem Hammer irgendwie kommen, aber er kann dagegen nichts tun, weil die Rechte halt bei einer bestimmten Agentur liegen. Und damit liegt es auch nicht mehr in seiner Hand, wie damit umgegangen wird, mit diesen rechten
natürlich auch irgendwie sehr fragwürdig ist von der von der Verhandlungspraxis. Und ich hatte mit den Spaß gemacht, ich habe der Tortenfrau da geschrieben,
Und hatte der irgendwie eine Mail geschrieben,
Eigentlich wollte ich nur von ihr wissen, ob das wirklich in ihrem Namen passiert, ob das tatsächlich auch äh in ihrem Sinne ist, hat sie nicht geantwortet und andere haben halt bei ihr aufs Facebook-Profil irgendwie ufgeknallt, was denn da passiert ist und die hat sie gelöscht. Also ich davon aus, dass sie weiß, worum es geht.
Mhm. Na, die nächste die nächste Torte muss ja auch bezahlt werden, ne?
Lastet schon in ihrem Sinne. Es interessant daran ist aber auch, wenn man jetzt das Foto hier nochmal sieht, nachdem die Bilder verkauft wurden, hatte jedes Foto von ihr eine äh so ein Wasserzeichen, wo dann halt die Seite ihrer Domain drauf stand.
Zu dem Moment äh war das auch nicht der Fall.
Gut, schauen wir mal, wie es da weitergeht, ne?
Genau.
Dass du nicht um achtzehnhundert Euro erleichterst.
Warte noch ein bisschen, meine Sorge ist, wenn das jetzt mit den Fotos äh losgeht und det sich gut durch äh äh setzen lässt, wie macht man denn weiter? Weil Musik, grade DJ-Mix oder so sind ein gefundenes Fressen, also das wenn das mit dem Foto gut funktioniert, ist die Frage, wie wird danach mit anderen Sachen umgegangen?
Also die Möglichkeiten sind wahrscheinlich ähnlich,
Weil die Urheberrechtsverletzung findet statt, wenn du bei dir quasi ein ein DJ-Mix von irgendwem laufen lässt oder irgendwie einbindest oder so, weil vielleicht sind das dann die nächsten Briefe.
Ja, den potenziellen Gesetzgebung beteiligten Zuhörern unseres Programms legen wir äh diese gesamtbedenken jetzt mal hier äh sozusagen nahe und äh dann,
Abteilung jetzt auch mal äh dicht machen, ne?
Ja, haben wir erstmal durchgemahnt.
Es gibt ja auch noch äh andere Ungereimtheiten äh auf diesem Planeten, insbesondere in den USA, die ja immer sehr modern sein wollen,
ähm und auch in Notsituationen niemals äh um eine Lösung verlegen sind.
Wir haben an sich eine sehr schöne Lösung einfallen lassen, als der äh Wirbelsturm Sandy äh die Ostküste heimsuchte,
und zwar war da ja gerade in Jersey und New York waren war da einiges unter Wasser und so und man konnte jetzt nicht so auf die öffentliche Verkehrsinfrastruktur bauen und man wollte natürlich sicherstellen, dass die Leute äh sich an den Wahlen beteiligen können.
Also nochmal zum äh als Rückblick äh der Sturm brach was war das? An einem Mittwoch, Donnerstag glaube ich so über die Region
herein und betraf New York extrem, aber noch sehr viel stärker eben die das Gebiet und New Jersey. Also ich meine New York
zwar also Stromausfall, Hochwasser, was weiß ich, U-Bahn war äh vollgelaufen. Es war nicht ganz so dramatisch. New Jersey sind eben natürlich mal wieder die ganzen Holzhäuser
äh weggeflogen und Küstenstreifen überflutet worden. Und am nächsten Dienstag war dann eben die äh Wahl zum,
Äh um den Präsidenten äh.
Es ist, glaube ich, der vierundvierzigste jetzt geblieben. Es hätte der fünfundvierzigste werden können, wenn ich nicht.
Okay, ich wollt's jetzt grade gar nicht durchzählen, aber na ja, man wollte sozusagen jetzt sicherstellen, dass eben auch alle äh wählen können und kam dann auf die tolle Idee, das doch per E-Mail zu machen, jetzt wo wir das Internet haben und so.
Ich meine, wahrscheinlich sind war das Wählen per E-Mail noch noch sicherer als die Wahlcomputer, die sie da benutzen.
Da ist was dran, ja. In gewisser Hinsicht aber auch nur.
Und ähm wir wissen natürlich alle, dass E-Mails nun wirklich jetzt nicht als äh Medium geeignet sind, da dem Ansprüchen eine Wahl gerecht zu werden, ja.
Ne, weder ist sie dann geheim noch äh ist sie frei.
Noch kann ich noch ist sie ist dieser Brief irgendwie gesichert und.
Unfeldbar, also es ist einfach verstößt einfach gegen alles.
Es ist eben also es ist einfach nicht geheim, ja und ich und ich könnte jetzt auf die Idee kommen und sagen, na gut, dann schreibe ich jetzt, nehme ich mir jetzt einfach die Liste.
Ist auch nicht autorisiert. Nein, ist gar nichts. Das ist einfach gar nichts.
Nein, ist gar nix. Ist also die die völlig.
Mal als mal eine Frage, wer soll denn das auszählen dann? Naja.
Na ja, pass auf, der Mail-Server, der Mälzer. So, der ist aber leider, das geht ja noch weiter. Der Mälzer ist dann leider platt gegangen.
Weil ganz viele Leute das benutzt haben.
Ganz viel erst benutzt haben. So und dann kriegten die Stress dazu sehr geehrter, äh sehr geehrter äh Bezirksoberwahlleiter, ich wähle so und so mit freundlichen Grüßen, ne? Und,
Denn war in einigen Bezirken waren die Mails aber platt und
hat sich der ein Verwaltungsangestellter, der war natürlich um eine Lösung mich verlegen und hat gesagt, ich kenne eine Infrastruktur, die bricht nicht zusammen, schickt mir eure Wahl doch mal an meinen privaten Account,
der hat dann irgendwie so äh ich, also Entschuldigung, man muss noch den Namen, dieses dieses Mannes, der äh der muss in diesem Fall genannt werden, da kann man jetzt keine Rücksicht nehmen. Äh wie hieß er denn, irgendwas mit Dörqem oder sowas?
Na ja egal.
Abteilung gut gemeint.
Ne, pass auf, geht ja noch weiter, dann sagt er, schickt das doch mal an meinen Hot-Mail-Account,
Christopher Dörking, ja, der sein, also eine Stratege vor dem Herrn. Sagt hallo, schickt das an meinen privaten Hotmade-Account. Ähm was heißt das, dass dann,
die Wahlergebnisse unverschlüsselt auf dem Server liegen, der Microsoft gehört, ne, also da da kann man das dem Ganzen noch eine ganz andere Ebene an an ähm an an.
Aber er wollte bestimmt nur helfen.
Er wollte nur helfen? Helfen wollte auch,
dann einfach mal geguckt hat, welche Sicherheitsfragen denn bei einem Passwort Reset für diesen Account gestellt werden?
Und hat sie dann wurde halt gefragt, wie denn der Geburtsname von äh so wie von seiner Mutter ist. Von Christopher Dörkens Mutter und dann hat die, hat Ashkan
mal den Geburtsnamen von äh Christopher Dörkins Mutter gegoogelt und hat dann den Account übernommen.
Und hat die Wahlergebnisse ausgezählt.
Hat naja, ich meine, der hat halt dann Wahlbeobachtungen.
Moderne Wahlbeobachtung, gell? Das ist echt geil, ja. Ich meine, das da sagt dann wieder auch wieder eine ganze Menge auch über die die Sicherheitssysteme von solchen Mailsachen aus, ja, also solche Trivialfragen, die sich so in null Komma nix äh äh nachrecherchieren lassen als
Absicherung, wenn man sein Passwort vergessen hat, das ist einfach so ein.
Also es ist ganz gefährlich, ist auch immer noch sehr weit verbreitet, dass es viele Anbieter machen, die dann,
Eine Auswahl von sechs Fragen haben und es tatsächlich, ja, Geburtstage der Mutter ist so was ganz häufiges und das ist halt das ist halt sehen die öffentliche Information, ja? Und grade bei so Privataccounts, äh die dann ähm von,
von wo man, wo sage ich mal, immerhin noch dein größter, dein größtes Risiko ist, dass einer aus deinem an deinem erweiterten Bekanntenkreis, was weiß ich, irgendein Ex-Freund, dein E-Mail,
dein E-Mail-Zugang haben möchte, ja das ist ja nun mal für Privatpersonen dann immer doch noch die größte Bedrohung. Ähm,
Bei denen sind solche Informationen einfach zu herauszufinden, ne, oder Name deines ersten Haustiers, ja. Das wissen Leute.
Du wahrscheinlich auch einfach schon mal geblockt. Ja, diese ganze, diese ganze, ich meine, wenn du deinen Passwort vergisst, ja,
und du möchtest sicherstellen, dir das als Anbieter, dass jemand dann den Zugriff darauf wiederbekommt? Dann würde ich einfach mal sagen, da lässt man sich einfach eine,
Adresse geben und macht dann so was wie Post-Ident, ja, sozusagen, also wirklich so, jetzt musst du dich auch mal autorisieren und jetzt kommst du halt nicht in zehn Minuten ran, weil du hast halt dein Passwort vergessen,
ja?
PayPal machte ziemlich konsequent. Also wenn ihr da einmal raus bist, hast du richtig Travel, um da wieder ranzukommen an ein Passwort. Was natürlich in dem Fall auch nicht.
In dem Fall auch.
Ja, ja, na klar, aber es ist also wenn's halt och um finde, einfach diese Art und Weise, finde ich, relativ vertrauenserweckend, also nicht ohne mit äh Sicherheitsfrage, denn hier, wie hieß dein Hündchen.
Das passt, Wort vergessen, weil es doch wieder keiner mehr.
Wahl wählen.
Gewinnt.
Wählen per E-Mail auf dem Account. Also.
Genau, also sollte uns irgendjemand noch zuhören, äh äh der der Meinung ist, dass es vielleicht dann doch noch eine gute Idee sein könnte und man müsse sich vielleicht nur ein bisschen mehr äh um die Details kümmern.
Geh bitte. Hör woanders. Nein.
Einfach einfach nein, ja, also es ist einfach, wenn wenn's irgendwas gibt, was geradezu nur vor Missbrauch, Fehlern, Absturz und allen denkbaren Problemen äh äh,
tropft, dann ist es einfach E-Mail, ja? Es ist wirklich das Letzte. Man muss sich nur seinen Spam angucken und dann weiß man, äh das sind Work, ja.
DE wäre das bestimmt nicht passiert.
Es ist überhaupt schon beunruhigend, dass E-Mail sozusagen auch so das Last-Ressort äh Ding ist mit irgendwie. Ich meine, wie viele Systeme schicken einem dann auch wirklich nach einer Anmeldung die Passwörter im Klartext zu und so weiter. Also so,
Dusel da draußen, nicht? Aber irgendwo gibt's halt auch nichts besseres. Das Internet ist einfach.
Zum Wählen. Na ja, also.
Gar nicht, aber auch sonst eigentlich.
Die Bauer Holland Stiftung ist nicht gemeinnützig. Nee, zumindest ein Jahr lang nicht. Ähm.
Beunruhigend.
Das war äh schon bei der Gründung der oder bei der Eintragung der Gemeinnützigkeit des Vereins digitale Gesellschaft äh, dass die irgendwie zweitausendneun, glaube ich, stattgefunden hat,
das Gerücht
weil wir bei der bei dem Gemeinnützigkeitsding eben geschrieben haben, wenn sollte sich der Verein digitale Gesellschaft auflösen, dann kommt das Geld äh,
muss, da musst du quasi einen jemanden benennen, einen gemeinnützigen Zweck, dem dieses Geld dann zukommt. Und dann sagten wir, ja, das geht dann an die Wau Holland Stiftung und da wurde dann schon so
Von den Finanzberatern Finanzbeamten gesagt, na ja nehmen sie mal jemand anders, das könnte ihrem Antrag helfen.
Denn Ende zweitausendzehn hat dann das Finanzamt Kassel auf Initiative des Hessischen Innenministeriums äh der Bau-Holland-Stiftung, die Gemeinnützigkeit entzogen, weil sie,
also weil die es ihr an Selbstlosigkeit mangele. Sie darf nicht in erster Linie Geld kassieren, in dem Fall nämlich für Wiki Leaks. Die war Holland Stiftung war oder,
ist die Hauptanlaufstelle für Spenden an das Projekt Wiki Leaks. Ähm
und verwaltet die Spenden dort auch, also es im Prinzip ist die Wau Holland Stiftung ein eine Art Kontrollgremium auch in dem Fall für wenn die irgendwie Geld haben wollen, dann müssen sie äh was weiß ich, die Rechnung ähm nach nachm
Prozess irgendwie äh oder die Mittel dafür wahrscheinlich vorher bei der Bauholland Stiftung bewilligen und das muss dann dem Satzungszweck entsprechend und so weiter.
Ja genau, also sie dürfen nur Geld äh erhalten, nach Vorlage von Belegen, die klarmachen, dass hier auch wirklich für das Projekt, was ähm ausgegeben wurde.
Und das im Sinne der äh der Heiligenzwecke der Satzung der.
Genau, da gehört zum Beispiel nicht zu Aufwendungen zur Verteidigung von äh Julian Assange. Ja. Der ja sozusagen nicht Wiki Leaks ist, sondern eben.
Genau. Ähm so und jetzt wurde aber trotzdem der war Holland Stiftung also gesagt, okay, äh hier scheint hier eine eine Stiftung zu haben, mit der ihr einfach nur Spenden sammelt für diesen äh für diesen durchgeknallten mit den weißen Haaren,
Ähm und sagten
Ende zweitausendzehn sagte das Finanzamt Kassel, dass die diese Stiftung offensichtlich nicht selbst zu sich wer hatte, aber noch gar keine Unterlagen, noch gar keine Belege, noch gar kein Rechenschaftsbericht von der Stiftung bekommen. Das hatten die also schon so auf
ihr braucht uns gar nicht euren Geschäftsbericht zu schicken, was ihr da macht, ist sowieso nicht äh gemeinnützig,
und die Stiftung zog nach Hamburg um. Ich glaube, das war in Reaktion darauf, bin mir aber nicht genau sicher
und das Finanzamt Hamburg änderte die Begründung auf ein Verstoß gegen das Gebot der Unmittelbarkeit. Das Gebot der Unmittelbarkeit besagt, dass eine,
gemeinnützige Organisation zwar Hilfspersonen engagieren kann, um ihre Ziele zu erreichen, dabei jedoch ein,
Kontrollverfahren haben muss, also ein verbindliches Kontrollverfahren. Und das also quasi eine ähm also das ist ein ein, ein.
Also ein nachvollziehbares.
Genau, ein nachvollziehbares Kontrollverfahren, das bis Ende zweitausendzehn hatte die äh Wahrhollein-Stiftung mit WikiLeaks nur mündliche Absprachen
hat Ende zweitausendzehn diese in einen Vertrag gegossen, der, sage ich mal, den Prozess, den sie ohnehin schon,
gelebt haben, dann auch schriftlich manifestierte. Denen aber das Finanzamt nicht äh rückwirkend anerkannt diesen Vertrag, weil der eben erst Ende zweitausendzehn ähm.
Entstanden ist.
Entstanden ist. So und dann ging jetzt irgendwie achtzehn Monate hin und her,
und der jetzige Stand, mit dem sich die Bauer Holland Stiftung offensichtlich auch zufrieden gibt, beziehungsweise nicht zufrieden, aber
äh sich darauf einlässt, sich nicht weiter dagegen zu wehren, weil eben jetzt auch achtzehn Monate schon ins Land gezogen sind, ist, dass das Finanzamt die Gemeinnützigkeit für zweitausendzehn nicht anerkennt,
und die Stiftung nicht dagegen klagt dafür aber die Gemeinnützigkeit für zweitausendelf ohne Probleme wieder hat.
Mit anderen Worten, alle Spender an die Wau-Holland-Stiftung im Jahre zweitausendzehn,
können ihre äh Spende nicht absetzen. Tja.
Ciao. Aber äh das ist jetzt nicht dauerhaft. Also diese Gemeinnützigkeit ist jetzt in dem Sinne nicht komplett verloren, sondern nur für diesen Zeitraum.
Nur für das genaue, für das Jahr zweitausendzehn.
Also zweitausendneun geht, äh zweitausendelf geht, zweitausendzwölf geht, aber zweitausendzehn nicht. Jetzt wäre natürlich interessant, wann das Haupt äh Spendenaufkommen für war. Ich würde vermuten, dass es zweitausendzehn war.
Das ist vorstellbar. Aber was heißt das jetzt ganz genau, dass du für das eine Jahr nicht gemacht wird, dass dann dafür äh ja du hast so eine, wie heißt das? Steuern anfallen oder was?
Na, du hast so eine, wie heißt das denn, du, das, also wird eine für mich bedeutet das eine Spende an eine gemeinnützige Organisation, kann ich.
Bescheinigung und die kannst du absetzen. Und wenn du jetzt da halt in dem Jahr zehntausend Euro dafür gespendet hast, kannst du die nicht anteilermäßig absetzen.
Absetzen heißt in dem Falle, das wird von meinem Brutto,
gehalt abgezogen. Bei der Versteuerung mit anderen Worten, je nachdem in welcher Steuerklasse ich bin, kann ich, sagen wir mal,
Wenn man jetzt in der höchsten Steuerklasse ist, glaube ich, so um die zweiundvierzig Prozent oder so, heißt das, ich spende zehntausend Euro an die Wau-Holland-Stiftung und zahle selber nur ähm
sechstausendachthundert und viertausendzweihundert zahlt im Prinzip der Staat, dadurch dass ich den Steuernachlass.
Mhm.
Schon bei elftausend.
Ja, dreitausendzwei,
zahl fünf acht und der Start zahlt vier zwei, ja. So und das ist nicht möglich und natürlich ist das ein ein ganz ganz entscheidender Punkt beim Spenden an ähm gemeinnützige Organisationen, dass man eben weiß, dass das der Spenden,
dass der Spendenbetrag eben steuerlich absetzbar ist. So, ist aber jetzt nicht der Fall. Aber für zweitausendelf ist jetzt wieder.
Wir beobachten das.
Wir beobachten das weiter. Wir bleiben bei Wiki Leaks ähm und da gab's jetzt einen interessanten äh Blogeintrag des Anwaltes von Bradley Manning.
Derjenige ist, der die ganzen geheimen Daten zugetragen hat, die zur Veröffentlichung des Collag Demage äh Video.
Mörder.
Äh, Entschuldigung, äh Mördervideos und wohl auch der ähm,
Geschichte geführt hat.
So und der Anwalt lässt jetzt verlautbaren, dass der äh Bradley Manning anbietet,
sich also was ist nochmal die deutsche Übersetzung sich schuldig zu bekennen, ne,
dass er sich schuldig bekennt für einige ähm,
Für einige äh Vorwürfe, die ihm gestellt werden, allerdings nicht für den Hauptvorwurf, Ading wie Annemi, also Findestilfe, beziehungsweise das ist äh im Prinzip Landesverrat. Ähm,
der Richterin anbietet
zum Beispiel sagt, ja, ich habe diese Daten, ich ich bekenne mich schuldig, die Daten weitergereicht zu haben und somit, weiß ich nicht, die Geheimhaltungspflicht verletzt zu haben. Ich bekenne mich aber nicht schuldig äh äh,
Hochverrat bekannt zu haben oder was. Und jetzt schreibt der Anwalt, ja,
Bradley Menning bietet dieses Tageständnis an und betont, dass sich dass es dabei keinen Deal gibt. Mit dem,
Mit der Regierung oder mit dem Gericht. Weil häufig ja auch ähm solche äh äh solche Schuldeingeständnisse mit einem, wie auch immer, gearteten Deal sich zusammen,
also man geht ja dadurch aus, dass davon aus, dass man dadurch, dass man ein Schuldgeständnis Schuldeingeständnis ausspricht, dass man dann eine ein milderes Urteil bekommt.
Weil man dem ganzen Gericht ja die die Arbeit spart einen die Beweise zu erbringen, weil wenn man geständig ist, äh erspart sich das Gericht dann eine Menge Arbeit.
Und ähm das Interessante ist, warum der Anwalt da jetzt so betont, dass es keinen äh Deal gibt, ist
natürlich der Julio A Sanchez, weil es könnte ja auch hier wieder die Frage im Raume stehen, äh dass Bradley Menning aussagen könnte, ja, ich wollte die Sachen gar nicht veröffentlichen, aber der Julio hat äh gesagt, das soll ich unbedingt machen und der hat mich angestiftet und dann hätten die USA natürlich wieder etwas äh um den
äh
um den Julio äh bei sich noch unbeliebter zu machen und äh ihn suchen zu können. Also ich denke, das ist da, warum das betont wird. Allerdings gibt's keine gab's erstmal keine weitere ähm,
Erklärung, was er jetzt genau zugeben wird und was also jetzt der,
Passieren wird, ist, dass es der Richterin Denise Lindt, äh ob liegen wird, ob sie dieses Teil schuld, Geständnis akzeptiert oder zurückweist,
Und selbst wenn es, wenn sie's akzeptiert, kann die US-Regierung auf der Klägerseite,
dagegen wieder einen Widerspruch einlegen. Es ist eigentlich nicht viel passiert, aber interessant ist, äh dass äh,
Februar zweitausenddreizehn das die Verhandlung dann eben losgehen soll und es wäre dann eben mal interessant, ob ähm Bradley Mening da mit einem Talgeständnis,
reingeht oder nicht.
Ja, auf jeden Fall scheint er jetzt doch ein bisschen weichgekocht zu sein nach.
Ja, das war auch neunhundert Tage oder was jetzt da in.
Drei Jahre ist ja irgendwie im Knast.
In Isolationshaft mehr oder weniger unter fürchterlichen Bedingungen. Also ich denke auch, dass der wahrscheinlich inzwischen soweit ist, dass er auf alles zugibt, Hauptsache der kriegt irgendwie mal ein ein Kissen.
Ja und freue mich mal, wenn ich das jetzt richtig interpretiere, dann ist so im Wesentlichen so, ja, äh meinetwegen, ich gebe ja irgendwie was zu, stecke mich in den Knast, aber äh schlage mir nicht gleich einen Kopf ab und gebe mir irgendwie noch irgendeine Überlebens äh Option so,
selbst wenn sie erst in zehn, fünfzehn Jahren ist, äh,
Gut, verlassen wir äh den internationalen äh Sektor gehen wir hier in die lokale Berichterstattung.
Ja, lokale Berichterstattung, spannende, spannende Geschichte. Wir erinnern uns, Freiheit statt Angst, Demo zweitausendneun,
Ähm da gab es den Mann in den äh im blauen T-Shirt, der äh am Rande dieser Demonstration von einem Polizisten verprügelt wurde.
Ähm davon gab es dann relativ ähm ausführliche Videoaufnahmen,
Klar, glaube ich, von insgesamt vier Kameras und äh,
Wenn ich mich nicht täusche, waren das äh genau, hat der CCC dann einen Zusammenschnitt aller erhältlichen Kameras, auch unter anderem beigesteuert damals, in auf denen dann im Zusammenschnitt im synchronisierten Zusammenschnitt
zu erkennen war, wie der Typ halt überhaupt nichts gemacht hat, überhaupt keinen da irgendwie provoziert hatte und relativ wahllos äh einfach einem vor die Mappe bekommen hat,
und im äh,
April wurde schon da äh einer dieser Polizist oder die beteiligten Polizisten wurden zu einer Geldstrafe von sechstausend Euro wegen Körperverletzung im Amt verurteilt,
aber deine Geldstrafe, die sie an das Gericht zu zahlen haben,
Und jetzt gab es ähm führte das Zivilverfahren wegen Körperverletzung äh endete in in einem zivilrechtlichen Vergleich. Das heißt, es landet nicht vor ähm vor dem Gericht,
sondern die äh Parteien einigen sich außergerichtlich auf,
zehntausend Euro Schmerzensgeld. Die zahlt jetzt allerdings die äh Landeskasse, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, ähm weil die weil diese Polizisten nicht selber haften.
Ja. Klingt nicht nach sehr viel, ne?
Wir haften nie selber.
Nee. Also die äh das im Moment, ich schaue jetzt mal, ich suche ganz kurz, wo es hier steht.
Ja, das wundert mich jetzt nicht, dass dass da der Staat quasi für seine Polizisten gerade zu stehen hat. Das ist ja auch.
Das Land Berlin musste diesen äh entsprechenden Vergleich zustimmen. So. Und das heißt, das Land Berlin zahlt jetzt äh zehntausend Euro an den man den blauen T-Shirt.
Hast du noch eine Erinnerung, wie es dem eigentlich danach ging? Also äh hat ja irgendwelche längeren hat er irgendwelche Schäden davon gehört.
Den nie kennengelernt ähm der hatte glaube ich einen Lippenabriss und äh,
Wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Also der hatte schon ernsthafte Verletzungen. Ähm,
Ich suche das gerade, ja. Ach so, ein, ein Arzt hatte damals bei Oliver H, einen Oberlippenabriss, Hautabschürfungen, Schwellung und eine Traumatisierung festgestellt. Kann ich aber auch verstehen. Ich meine, die Traumatisierung, wenn du da spontan mal einen,
Der stand, der hat da irgendwie sein Fahrrad rumgeschoben und hatte, ich glaube, der war noch nicht mal in einer Demo beteiligt.
Ja. Achte auch das noch.
Ja, also es gibt da ein Video zu ähm ich habe den noch nie kennengelernt, also ähm.
Ja, zehntausend Euro ist wirklich lächerlich, weil das ist vor allem ist sowas wirklich traumatisierend, ne. Also, weil grad so äh insbesondere, wenn's auch noch sonderlich äh ungerechtfertigt ist, ist äh einfach schlimm.
Ähm ansonsten nennt der Anwalt die äh die diese zehntausend Euro ungewöhnlich hoch. Denn was noch anzumerken ist, ja, ähm im letzten Jahr gab es vierhundertsiebzehn Strafverfahren wegen Körperverletzung im Amt,
und von vierhundertsiebzehn Strafverfahren gab es drei Verurteilungen. In einem ganzen Jahr. Äh Schmerzensgeldzahlungen sind dabei nur Einzelfälle,
Und ähm da gab's äh die anderen beiden Fälle sind ganz interessant. Ein Hertha-Fan hat im Februar zweitausend Euro bekommen, weil er beim Fußballspiel vom Einsatzwagen der Polizei umgenietet wurde
und ähm,
in Aachen hat jemand im Februar sechstausend Euro bekommen, weil er vom Polizeihund gebissen wurde und zweitausendneun bekam ein Nordrhein-Westfale einhunderttausend Euro,
weil er im betrunkenen Zustand ein Mädchen fand, einen Mädchen von Fahrenzug gestört hatte und die Polizei ihn daraufhin so so zusammengeschlagen hat, dass er jetzt querschnittsgelähmt ist,
Das sind die drei Fälle von.
Hunderttausend Euro für Querschnittsgelähmt. Alter Falter.
Also insofern muss man sagen, sind die zehntausend schon.
Das ist schon ordentlich. Gemessen an einer Querschnittslähmung.
Ja gut, so kann man das auch sehen, ne? Äh.
Äh wie weit, also wie weit dann doch mal eine Schmerzen zu der Zahlung geht, sagen wir es mal so. Also es ist ja wirklich, hat wirklich Seltenheit wert. Überhaupt Verfahren in dem Fall bis zu Ende irgendwie durchzuspielen und die nicht irgendwie einzustellen.
Ja, aber ich finde diese Schmerzensgelder sind einfach zu niedrig.
Na klar, keine Frage. Also hunderttausend für eine Querschnittslähmung ist definitiv ein ganz beschissener Deal.
Jeden Fall. Das hast du in drei Monaten ausgegeben für die Umstellung der Lebensumstellung. Äh ja, also es ist furchtbar. Na gut, lass uns weitermachen.
Ähm das Verfahren gegen die Antiterrordatei geht los,
Verfassungsgericht wir erinnern uns die Anti-Terror-Datei wurde zweitausendsechs beschlossen gegen islamistische Terroristen
ist so eine Meterdatenbank, wo irgendwie auch ausländische Geheimdienste, ohne jede Kontrolle äh Daten reinfüttern,
Und die einzige Voraussetzung ist, äh dass es irgendwie Anhaltspunkte gibt. Ähm,
Und es geht in dieser Datenbank landen dann natürlich auch irgendwie Bekannte, von mutmaßlichen Terroristen, Leute, die zufällig mal in der gleichen, im gleichen Cafe oder gleichen Moschee waren. Und das,
ähm das Problem mit dieser Datenbank ist, dass sie eben Polizei und Geheimdienst verbindet ähm der Geheimdienst darf ja bekanntermaßen im Prinzip alle observieren, aber nicht vor Gericht bringen,
die Polizei für jede äh Observation, Richterentscheid braucht, das heißt in der Anti-Terror-Datei hat die Polizei Zugriff auf Informationen,
von Geheimdiensten gesammelt wurden, also Informationen, die der Polizei nicht zustehen.
Und ähm gleichzeitig gibt es dieses Problem, dadurch dass es ein geheimdienstliches äh Ding ist
jemand, der einmal in dieser Antiterrordatei eingetragen ist, eben Sigma hat und dann dazu einfach nicht wieder los wird. Du musst ja erstmal da auf den Trichter kommen, dass du da überhaupt drin stehst. Und ähm,
bei diesem Verfahren ähm steht also jetzt,
Unter anderem der CC als Sachverständiger vor dem Bund dem dem Bundesverfassungsgericht zur Verfügung,
Und das Urteil wird in ein paar Monaten erwartet und betrifft dann natürlich auch die Rechtsextremismusdatei von, über die wir schon vor einigen Folgen gesprochen haben, die ja im Prinzip das gleiche in grün ist,
Das heißt, da ist jetzt eine äh relativ interessante ähm Gerichtsentscheidung,
über die Trennung von Geheimdienst und Polizei in Deutschland zu erwarten. Da habe ich jetzt habe ich aber sehr schnell mich sehr sehr kurz abzuarbeiten.
Ja. Aber also diese Anhörung ist jetzt sozusagen schon abgeschlossen, aber man weiß jetzt noch nicht.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Genommen wurde oder.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die nicht vielleicht noch ähm,
Noch irgendwie weitermachen, noch mal irgendwie eine Anhörung machen oder wie wie überhaupt so ein Gerichtsverfahren vom Bundesverfassungsgericht genau läuft, aber auf jeden Fall wird's dann irgendwie
in den nächsten Monaten irgendwann ein Urteil dazu geben
wer ähm sich dafür interessiert, es gab natürlich da für die ganze Sache relativ viel Aufmerksamkeit und äh Frank Rieger hat dann auch irgendwie äh Interviews gegeben. Da kann man das alles nochmal
in Ruhe nachlesen die Argumentation, die ich jetzt grade aufgrund der fortgeschrittenen Zeit so kurz zusammengefasst habe.
Okay.
Ich verlinke auch mal die den äh die Pressemitteilung, wo nämlich die Verfahrensgliederung und so weiter äh bekanntgegeben ist. Also Urteilsverkündung da in einiger Zeit zu erwarten.
Keine Logbuchnetzpolitik Sendung ohne äh GEMA,
Würde ich sagen, ne.
Ja, von mir aus,
das ist ein Thema, was ich leider ein bisschen ausgelassen hatte in den in der letzten Zeit und zwar gab es da tatsächlich eine Petition, die auch erfolgreich war,
Erfolgreich im Sinne von fünfzigtausend Zeichner bekommen und dadurch die
Anhörung vor dem Petitionsausschuss gewonnen. Wir wissen, dass ich äh
oder wir hatten die Kritik an Petition ja auch schon in einem vor vorherigen Logbuch zusammengefasst, dazu dann auch nochmal der Link in den Shownotes. Ähm,
Da gab's also jetzt die die äh Anhörung dieses äh dieser Petentin,
Die also argumentierten, dass diese GEMA Vermutung äh nicht in Ordnung ist, weil,
Die Gebervermutung ja sagt, dass die GEMA grundsätzlich erstmal Anspruch hat auf ihre Gebühren. Wenn du nicht beweisen kannst, dass der Künstler nicht bei der GEMA ist,
Wir erinnern uns an den äh Fall der Musikpiraten, die diesen Creative Comments Musik äh Sampler gemacht haben.
Und dann der der GEMA äh zum Opfer fielen. Und genau um diese Gamervermutung geht es,
Und da sagte dann der Max, also sie haben dann eben vorgeführt, dass der der ähm
der Nachweis äh nicht in Ordnung ist, dass dass man den selber bringen muss und die Argumentation ist also, wenn die GEMA Geld fordert, dann muss sie auch selber nachweisen können, dass sie dazu auch berechtigt ist, sagte dann der Christian Hufgard
der Vorsitzende des Vereins der Musikpiraten und die grobe Antwort war dann von Max Stadler
der im Petitionsausschuss des Deutschen Bundestags für die FDP sitzt und Staatssekretär im Justizministerium ist,
Dass es nicht möglich ist, dass die GEMA ihre Arbeit macht, wenn sie in jedem Einzelfall nachweisen müsste, äh dass ein Themapflichtiges Repertoire gespielt worden ist. Mit anderen Worten.
Bleibt alles, wie es ist.
Bleibt alles wie's ist, aber gut, dass wir mal drüber gesprochen haben.
Schön, dass ihr fünfzigtausend unterschrieben habt.
Ja und vor allem äh wiederholt sich hier genau die Diskussion, die wir jetzt vorhin schon hatten mit den Bildern, ne äh und Urheberrecht und Voranmeldung und so weiter. Also auch hier wird einfach erstmal gesagt, so och ja, ist uns egal, ob da irgendwie, ob wir Recht haben oder nicht, äh zahlt doch erstmal
unser Geld kommen. Ja, schön. Ja, also das ist auch echt geil.
Ja, ja.
Wirklich unfassbar. Ja,
Naja gut, ich meine, da sieht man auch mal wieder, wie wie effizient äh äh dieses dieses äh Petitionsspiel ist. Ich
viele haben immer noch so ein bisschen so diese Schockwelle äh von Zensursulada äh im Kopf, nur die Petition als solche war an der Stelle im Prinzip genauso sinnlos. Wichtig war
die Tatsache, dass man sich erstmals überhaupt zusammen gerottet hat
um da den Protest gemeinsam zu formulieren, aber wer ist sozusagen nur die Petition gewesen, hätte es, glaube ich, auch niemanden interessiert, so,
ähm kam's dann eben anders, aber
Glaube, dass dieses ganze Petitionsgeschreie, wir müssen jetzt hier alle unterschreiben und wenn er jetzt hier nicht unterschreibt, er unterschreibt die Welt unter. Das wird jetzt nicht mehr lange äh greifen, insbesondere bei so,
mega zahnlosen Geschichten wie der Petition, ja, wo man dann hingehen kann und sagt, irgendwie
finden euch alle doof und ihr riecht nach Lulu und dann sagen die so na und? Und zwar egal,
Ja keiner riecht so gut nach Lulu wie wir.
Riechen zwar nach Lulu, aber es ist unser.
Ja, ja. Und du zahlst. Ja, also wahrscheinlich muss man sich ohnehin mal ein bisschen Gedanken darüber machen, äh effizientere ähm.
Fiese daran ist ja immer noch, dass dann halt immer noch von von Machtseite damit irgendwie kokettiert wird, wie toll die Demokratie funktioniert, hier dürfen fünfzigtausend Leute eine Petition unterschreiben
und das tun die auch und wir lassen es zu, aber im Endeffekt geht uns da trotzdem am Allerwertesten vorbei.
Mit jeder Petition, die sich nach der Anhörung und Luft auflöst, also von Mal zu Mal frustrierender, so.
Ja, ich denke, ich meine, wenn man jetzt mal bei den Aktiven, glaube ich, äh nachkratzt, wenn ich auch so Markus äh da als Äußerung so über die Zeit äh,
Hinsicht mal zusammenfassen mag, ist sehr viel effizienter Leute dazu zu motivieren, sich wirklich bei ihren Abgeordneten zu beschweren und da äh unmittelbaren Einsatz zu machen. Und ich glaube, das ist auch noch etwas, was viele Leute,
nicht tun,
und das was aber wahrscheinlich am Ende sehr viel mehr bewirken würde, aber ich glaube, diese Verbindung ist irgendwie noch nicht so richtig da,
Da würde sich wahrscheinlich sehr viel mehr lohnen mal über etwas kreativere ähm Aktionen nachzudenken. So,
Gibt's noch ein.
Ein Thema gibt's noch ganz kurz.
Auslandsbericht.
Noch rein, ja. In Ägypten und Australien gibt's jetzt äh Netzsperren. Fangen wir an mit Ägypten,
da ist es echt spannend, da sieht man mal, dass Fall von kulturellen Unterschieden da hat jetzt der Generalstandsstaatsanwalt der Republik Ägypten, Abdel Mahmut, äh ein Brief,
an das Mysterium für Telekommunikation, Information und Inneres oder die Ministerien geschrieben und hat aufgefordert, dass sie endlich äh Maßnahmen ergreifen, um Webseiten mit pornographischen Inhalten zu sperren,
Denn seit einem äh Gerichtsverfahren vor zweitausendneun vor dem Oberverwaltungsgericht in Ägypten ähm
ist das jetzt also erlaubt, da gibt's keine äh äh Probleme und es demonstrierten Salafisten für Netzsperren,
Es gab also eine eine Demonstration von Salafisten in Ägypten für Netzsperren. Und die Gruppe der Zusammenschluss von denen nennt sich ähm
Pure Net.
Für, damit's keinen Porno mehr gibt sozusagen.
Ja, die wollen kein Poren im Internet haben.
Was es neu ist.
Ich finde das eigentlich ganz scharf, dass es Demonstrationen für Netzsperren gibt, also ähm so.
So
Hey, zensiert das Internet, wir kommen da ist Porn drin.
Ja, du lachst irgendwie, ich glaube, das wird uns hier auch noch äh ich meine, das hatten wir auch in gewisser Hinsicht hier in anderer Form schon, ja.
Ja, aber okay, also ich ich.
Ja, ja, lass mal hier diese Kirchenwahnsinnigen irgendwie, ja, die sich ja hier schon gegen Homosexualität et cetera auch gerne äh äh öffentlich da auf die Straße stellen. Das wird nicht mehr so lange dauern und da haben wir diese Diskussion auch äh im im Kreis Modus.
Australien, ist der andere Fall. Ähm da haben sie jetzt einen,
Da haben sie im Prinzip das gemacht, was in äh in Deutschland war äh oder was in Deutschland mit der Zensur Debatte stand, sie haben quasi eine ähm Zensur, Infrastruktur errichtet für Netzsperren,
im Bezug auf kinderpornografisches Material,
Ähm das Machen die zwei größten Provider Australien sowieso schon seit zwei Jahren freiwillig,
Und jetzt sollen's eben alle machen. Die Liste soll Interpol liefern
Und äh Andre stellte dann bei seinem Artikel im Netz Org dann auch mal die berechtigte Frage,
wer, wenn nicht Interpol sollte in der Lage sein, äh international äh solche Kriminelle auch tatsächlich zu verfolgen
und dafür zu sorgen, dass die halt ja vor Gericht kommen und dass ihre Kisten beschlagnahmt werden als Beweismittel und das Material gelöscht wird,
ja? Interessant war dabei, dass ja selbst die Bundesregierung als Lehre aus ähm.
Aus der ganzen Zensursula-Debatte,
Eine Pressemitteilung rausgegeben hat zweitausend im Mai zweitausendelf, wo sie selber sagten,
Löschen statt sperren, ja? Und ähm,
Das heißt, selbst die Bundesregierung hat's gelernt, in Australien haben sie es nicht gelernt und da gibt's jetzt natürlich auch schon wieder die Christen, das ist dann die Australian Quiz Chill Lobby, ähm,
das aus dem Internet gelöscht wird weil die Teenager das sonst sehen können,
Ja, also das ist ein ein großes Problem, offensichtlich in Australien, äh unter dem das Land leidet, dass die dass die Teenager Zugang zu Pornographie haben,
und die Australian Christian Lobby fordert, also Mandorian Internetfilters, äh um da die vom Prokrastinieren, sage ich mal,
Ja, schön. Also äh.
Was machst du in deinem Zimmer? Du prokrastinierst doch nicht etwa wieder.
Nö, ich lerne für Bio.
Oh Mann.
Ja. Man sieht, die Welt ist verrückt und wir können nix dagegen tun. Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber wir probieren's äh äh zumindest und äh geben uns hier gibt uns hier Mühe, den Wahnsinn zusammen zu fegen. Ronny, und du warst dabei. Vielen Dank.
Ja, bitte, gerne. Gerne.
Lest alle das Kraftfutter Mischwerk, fünfzehn Artikel am Tag.
Genau, lest alle Artikel.
Ohne Bilder jetzt.
Text.
Genau.
Genau, den schlanken Kuchen müsst ihr euch dann woanders äh kaufen.
Genau. Den gibt's überall anders, gibt's den übrigens noch.
Na ja, ist auf jeden Fall, wir wissen ja, wie das ist so, wenn's einmal im Netz ist, kriegt man zu schnell nicht wieder raus. So wie mit der Dummheit. Die kehrt auch immer wieder.
Und der Pornographie.
Ja ja und.
Die Salafisten und die Christen vereinigen.
In Salafisten und Christen, die irgendwie durch die Straßen sperrt, das Netz.
Und die Prokrastinisten, die sind gleich hinterher.
Ansonsten bedaure ich äh wir haben ja gerade mal über das Geld gesprochen, bedauere ich wirklich äh dass wenn ich überlege so
Drangzeit äh wie viele zehntausend Euro mir entgangen sind, weil ich mich nie gegen Körperverletzung durch Polizisten bewährt habe.
Du hast es wahrscheinlich auch keine äh Videos mit vier Objektiven irgendwie gehabt.
Ja, also die, die interessant, also wirklich einfach mal ein Learning, ja, äh geht zu den Demos und filmt das alles, ne? Ist ja immer in linken Kreisen wird das debattiert, äh wollen wir filmen bei den Demos.
Lasst euch verprügeln und äh.
Nee, aber die.
Die ganze Zeit über deinem Kopf äh äh mitfliegen lässt sozusagen, der dir immer so folgt, wie so ein kleines Hündchen und immer äh ordentlich auf dich drauf hält, dann gehst du einfach da rein in die Polizeibrigade und sagst, komm doch.
Einer eine abgerissene Oberlippe. Schon hat's die ganze Nummer finanziert. Ab dann scheint der schwarze.
Okay, ich sehe schon, wir müssen hier das Ende einleiten, sonst leitet irgendjemand für uns das Ende ein. Ja, das war's. Die äh,
Vierundvierzigste Ausgabe war das jetzt schon. Es geht weiter. Bis bald.
Bis bald. Tschau.